in the many decades since it was first
published a Lord of the Rings has
remained one of the world's most popular
novel series and Peter Jackson's iconic
movie trilogy has only made the story
endure that much longer being so popular
of course you're bound to get a few
crazy fan theories thrown into the mix
here are a few of the Lord of the Rings
series that if true would turn the whole
of middle-earth on its head even casual
Tolkien fans will have heard of one of
the stories most notorious criticisms to
keep it short why didn't the fellowship
just use the Eagles to fly to Mount Doom
and destroy the ring on the surface it
seems like a fair question to ask and
there are plenty of perfectly reasonable
answers to it too but one fan theory in
particular goes beyond just explain why
the Eagles weren't up for the task
it actually suggests that using them as
transport was the plan all along
this theory suggests that after being
saved by the Eagles from his
imprisonment on top of orthanc Gandalf
the size of this winged transportation
is surely the best way to catch Sauron
by surprise and destroy the ring the
crux of this theory rests on the
suggestion that when Gandalf the Grey
engages in combat with the Balrog is now
iconic final line should be taken
literally the idea is that he's just not
telling his companions to get out of
Moria he's trying to communicate his
plan to use the Eagles to reach Mordor
of course this doesn't work and by the
time he returns as Gandalf the White
he's got a whole new agenda to pursue of
course Gandalf could also have just been
telling the Fellowship to quit their
daughter Ling and get the heck out of
Dodge just go with whatever works for
you
Smeagol is one of the most pitiful
characters from The Lord of the Rings
and in a way one of the most lovable to
anyone with the heart should be able to
feel for the poor wretch as he struggles
with a centuries-long obsession with a
powerful force beyond his own
comprehension then of course there's
Gollum the other side of his split
personality in the film's Gollum
basically represents all the bad stuff
he's hateful violence and willing to
stop at nothing to get hold of his
precious ring while most people
generally accept that these two
characters make up a kind of multiple
personality disorder on spiegel's parts
one fun theory suggests a wholly
different take rather than simply
writing off Gollum a Smeagol zville side
this theory goes out on the lemon claims
that Gollum is a legitimate personality
or that stone that stems from within the
One Ring itself this theory rests on the
fact that's when Bilbo has possession of
the ring he acts very similarly to
Smeagol skaaland personality
towards the end of the story Frodo
begins to act this way to ensure to
anyone tempted by the ring and not just
Smeagol can exhibit snippets of this
identity and upon giving into the Rings
dominance would themselves be completely
consumed by it it would have happened to
Bilbo it almost happened to Frodo and it
probably happened to you too during the
opening chapters of the Fellowship of
the Ring it's revealed that Frodo's
parents drowned in a boating incident
well this was officially an accident
darker rumors suggested that his mother
actually tried to push his father into
the water and he pulled her in with him
accident or not that was the story as
far as everyone knew it until now
according to one Reddit fan theory the
given story of this so-called accident
has actually a misdirect instead to the
theory proposes that it was none other
than Gollum himself who killed his
future masters parents as they coasts
along the water after dinner in the
moonlight while the poster admits that a
coincidence would have been a stretch
they do make some solid arguments for
their theory for one thing a golem was
searching around for his lost ring at
the time of Frodo's parents death still
looking for Bilbo Baggins of the Shire
Frodo's father was named Drogo Baggins
so who's to say that villainous creature
didn't simply bump off the first Baggins
he ran across and able to find the ring
on Drogo's body Gollum could have then
had it South drawn towards the one rings
master while it takes a little
stretching to fit with Tolkien's
narrative this theory disrupt the
tantalizing prospect of a version of the
story in which Frodo discovers that the
creature who benefited so frequently
from his mercy actually killed his own
parents okay so this theory is kind of a
twofer let's start with the more
clear-cut one that Tolkien included
cannibalism in his trilogy
more specifically the idea that Grima
Wormtongue ate Hobbit flesh
during the scouring of the shire chapter
in The Return of the King Saruman
reveals that his Lackey Wormtongue
killed Frodo's corrupt relative low
though
during the scene the Fallen wizard
states worm killed your chief stabbed
him in a sleep I believe buried him I
hope though worm has been very hungry
lately and this the last little zinger
that has led many to question if worm
sung actually straight-up ate Luthor's
body in an attempt to stave off his
extreme hunger if he did this kind of
mistreatment on Salman's part would go a
long way in explaining what push
Wormtongue into finally snapping and
killing his master cannibalism aside
however another theory suggests that the
idea that saw a man's mistreatment of
worm tongue wasn't
turning him into the pale decrepit
wretch that he became it was actually
transforming him into an orc in other
words after creating his hybrid or acai
earlier in the story as possible that
Saruman was experimenting once more this
time with warping a man into an entirely
new breed of orc
it's a chilling thought that could have
had drastic repercussions for
middle-earth if Wormtongue hadn't been
killed before the transition could fully
take place
here's another Wormtongue theory though
this one is at least a little less
grotesque this theory has to do with the
rings of power but not the ones you'll
have encountered before
instead it tackles the idea that Saruman
might have attempted to craft rings of
his own after all Saruman emulated the
Dark Lord in most of the things that he
did so why not make rings of his own -
there are multiple instances in the
trilogy was suggested that Saruman has
an interest in the other rings of power
when Gandalf tells the story of his
captivity at the Council of Elrond for
instance he specifically points out that
he'd noticed her Saruman was wearing a
ring on top of that when Saruman
announces his treachery to Gandalf he
refers to himself as Saruman ring maker
if you can assume from these sensors
Saruman was busy making his own ring and
why would he stop making one for himself
wouldn't you want to take after Sauron
and create other rings to use as a tool
for the domination of others the same
way Sauron took control of the Nazgul
what's more this theory suggests that
none other than Grima Wormtongue is in
possession of one of solomon's rings
forcing him to surface was idli master
without question until the very end
fans of the Lord of the Rings books will
be very familiar with Tom Bombadil this
enigma of a character is a mysterious
and the speak of the powerful being that
lives out in the old forest just beyond
the edge of the Shire
now summers no interest in the affairs
of outsiders or the war going on in
middle-earth well that's what he says at
least one theory however suggests that
Tom Bombadil is none other than the
witch king himself okay don't laugh too
hard before you hear at least a few of
the arguments in favor of this theory
for instance when the hobbits run into
the merry old fellow in the Fellowship
of the Ring Thomas a noticeable glint in
his eye when the Black Riders are
mentioned and then there's the fact that
he can see Frodo clearly when the Hobbit
is wearing the one ring just like the
witch-king of Weathertop
and when Tom puts a magical piece of
jewellery on his own finger it has no
effect on him much in the same way that
it wouldn't have any effect on a true
servant of Sauron either of course if by
some crazy happenstance
theory were to be true it would mean
Frodo was saved and looked after by the
witch-king for a considerable chunk of
time which all things considered seems
unlikely early on in the two towers
Aragorn Legolas and Gimli chase a troop
of oxen or a chi that have captured
their hobby friends merry and pippin
eventually they discover their enemies
have been destroyed and the hobbits are
missing as they prepare to head into the
forest of fame gone to search for them
they run into an interesting character
in the book at least as they sit
arresting by a fire in the dark they
suddenly spots an old bent man leaning
on a staff and wrapped in a great cloak
with his wide brimmed hat pulled down
over his eyes before the trio can react
the man disappears without a trace when
they meet Gandalf shortly afterward he
clarifies that it wasn't him and so it
must have been Saruman however one
theory suggests that it was none other
than radagast the brown
they give away there's little to no
proof anywhere that Saruman ever wears a
hat the brown wizard on the other hand
frequently does but a gasp plays a
significant part in the hobbits for the
G and makes a brief appearance in the
book version of Fellowship of the Ring
but if this theory is true it would
indicate that radagast was more active
during the War of the Ring than anyone
could have guessed it strange to think
of three hairs particularly enticing but
in the Fellowship of the Ring that's all
Gimli asked for when Galadriel offers
him a parting gift on the surface this
presence seems cute enough if a little
odd a Gimli is in the first person to
wanton and Galadriel golden tresses way
back in the first stage the elf Lord
Fyodor requested a strand of hair from
Calabria three times it was often said
by the elves the light of the last two
trees of Valinor had endured in
Galadriel hair and this inspired
feyenoord to create the legendary jewels
no now says Syl morels her fear nor was
turned down repeatedly and never got his
hands on even a single strand of
collaterals hair but her to them bestow
three hairs on Gimli is a seriously big
deal especially since Gimli is a dwarf
part of a race that doesn't exactly get
along well with the elves all of this
has inspired a theory that the three
hairs are actually the great opening
gesture in an act of diplomacy peace and
reconciliation between the two racers
the fact that Galadriel decides his more
worthy of this gift than one of the
greatest elf Lord who's ever lived
is one heck of a statement and if Gimli
eventually managed to set the three
golden hairs an imperishable crystal as
he claims it may have ultimately
precipitated a lasting peace between
elves and Dwarfs
for Warner's falsi Hobbit trilogy could
be pretty fun it was exciting to some of
the time and you can't say it wasn't
colorful but let's be honest it was also
a bit of a train wreck
from all of its overstuffed storylines
lengthy battle scenes and ridiculous CGI
1 Prix and theorists are suggested an
explanation that fixes the entire fiasco
with a clever twist it's all a tall tale
from Bilbo's perspective see over the
course of his life
Bilbo developed something of a love for
storytelling and he's not afraid of
embellishing these stories from time to
time either at the Council of Elrond
when asked to tell his story he has to
start with the caveat that is actually
the true story saying if somewhat firmly
tell its otherwise I asked them to
forget it and forgive me
in short Bilbo loves to exaggerate his
stories and The Hobbit films are
actually a depiction of Tolkien's
classic novel from mr. Baggins own
perspective talk about a useful cop-out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]